it's Friday and that means it's time for
a man can't wear a political t-shirt now
to the gym Joe Biden is too bipartisan
and the most unexpected Lego character
of all is unveiled joining us now with
all the details
is Raymond Arroyo Fox News contributor
New York Times bestselling author of the
upcoming will Wilder the amulet of power
all right Raymond so a veteran and Troy
Missouri was forbidden to wear what he
was forbidden to wear a t-shirt Laura
now we're starting to see this trend
you've been reporting on it all week
first it was the Covington kids were
called out for wearing the maggots now
staff sergeant Jake Talbot says he was
working out at the gym wearing his
t-shirt that says 2016 Trump for
president he's behind when the owner
approached him and he'll tell you the
rest
I just left cdy Fitness here and Troy
worked it out started the owner lettuce
came out to me and said that my Trump
sure that I had on was offensive and
that I needed to remove it in order to
work out there and it's like racism army
vet says he's worn the shirt several
times before and it's never been a
problem the owner of the gym responded
in a now-deleted Facebook post where she
said I'm deeply saddened by the amount
of hate this event has garnered I will I
will personally and publicly continue to
defend my stance for tolerance and
against hate no matter the financial
consequence I don't believe our gym
should be a political forum for anyone I
want everyone to feel safe and
comfortable there the staffs okay wait a
second okay so does this mean all
political messages at this particular
gym have to be checked at the door
because that's going to be interesting
so so now your free speech rights and
your ability to believe whatever you
believe has got to be checked at the gym
because you're a conservative that's
what this is ridiculous say you were
striking a blow for tolerance by telling
a guy you can't wear that you're
offending people all right I want to
talk about Joe Biden because he's been
teasing that he might make a run the
White House or maybe a slow jog to the
White House in 20 to 20 20 but now his
bipartisanship his previous
bipartisanship
coming back to bite him in the new
radical era that we live in
allora Uncle Joe is clearly making a run
for the presidency hasn't announced it
yet but critics are pouncing on him in a
New York Times piece entitled Joe
Biden's paid speech buoyed the GOP in
Midwest battleground we're in it's
revealed get this Biden praised a
Republican congressman fred Upton as one
of the finest guys have ever worked with
so help me God some on the Left are
saying this is a disqualifier for the
Democratic nomination when a former veep
is taking it very seriously lor III get
in trouble I read in New York Times a
day that I them one of my problems is if
I were to run for president
I like Republicans okay bless me Father
for I have sinned if he were a little
bit younger he I would say he would
already I mean everyone else might might
as well just forget about it Iran I mean
he's a little long in the tooth but
that's why he's a threat because he
could get some independent lawyers with
that message in the Latino already there
so stupidly abrasion AOC and Kamala
Harris and Bernie Joe Biden looks
practically Republican there pushed him
out of the party what if I ever feel
what he said to me at Joel's house that
time you want to do it you do it go
ahead God's honest truth Ingraham you're
my ear my call the right-wingers you're
my favorite every moment Jay Carney was
this press second at the time I thought
he was gonna die he's like laughing oh
my god writing in the corner in the
corner now finally there is a new Lego
in town my son's gonna be very excited
because he's a Lego maniac familiar face
what yes now Laura this is more of the
blind partisanship continued here's the
trailer of the lego movie to the latest
Lego character appears at the end watch
for
[Music]
Superman the lego movie takes place the
imagination of a boy well in this
sequence of the new movie it takes place
in the imagination of the boy's sister
where her heroes spring to life now
here's the side by side of the real ruth
bader in the LEGO version by the way
these are going to be on sale you will
be able to buy this the action figure
that's a terrible rotation I spent time
with her that looks more like Joel
Stephens that's a horrible this one
sells gloves in all for 20 bucks and
parently has a lifetime warranty and I
think they'd like the real ruth bader to
have that same article there are a new
series of character they're doing one
character in multiple incarnations in
the lego Paree movie they've released
some images will show you those Laura
this one may look very familiar
the Laura Ingraham Lego Oh is this
amazing Laura in space this one really
the likeness is amazing this is like a
Lego chair double and this is my
favorite I think your eyes and lips on
the news Lego so okay that's terrifying
yeah well joke on a diet don't go wait
in line to get that leg do you know that
that gavel that day Ruth Bader had that
be the game of whack-a-mole with a Lego
ball and Legos call the Lego figure